maybe this is me
uh talking to the audience a little bit
because i get these days
so many messages advice on how to like
learn stuff okay my
this this this is not me being mean i
think this is quite a profound actually
is you should google it oh yeah
like one of the uh
like skills that you should really
acquire as an engineer
as a researcher as a thinker like one
there's two
two complementary skills like one is
with a blank sheet of paper with no
internet to think deeply
and then the other is to google the crap
out of the questions you have like
that's actually a skill i don't
people often talk about but like doing
research like pulling at the thread like
looking up different words
going into like github repositories with
two stars
and like looking how they did stuff like
looking at the code
or going on twitter seeing like there's
little pockets of brilliant people that
are like having discussions
like if you're a neuroscientist go into
signal processing community if you're an
ai person going into the
psychology community like like switch
communities that keep searching
searching searching
because it's so much better
to invest in like finding somebody else
who already solved your problem
then is to try to solve the problem and
because they've
often invested years of their life like
entire communities
are probably already out there who have
tried to solve your problem
i think they're the same thing i think
you go try to solve the problem
and then in trying to solve the problem
if you're good at solving problems
you'll stumble upon the person who
solved it already
yeah but the stumbling is really
important i think that's a skill that
people should really put especially in
undergrad
like search if you ask me a question how
should i get started in deep learning
like especially
like that is just so google
like the whole point is you google that
and you get a million pages
and just start looking at them yeah
start pulling at the thread start
exploring start taking notes start
getting it advice from a million people
that already like spent
their life answering that question
actually
oh well i mean that's definitely also
yeah when people like ask me things like
that i'm like trust me the top answer on
google is much much better than anything
i'm going to tell you
right yeah
you